federico bienvenido france24 y para
comenzar le doy las gracias a aportarnos
algo de su tiempo para discutir este
tema tan delicado para su familia quiero
preguntarle primero porque se retractó
el comité científico el concepto de
ustedes
cumple o no se cumple el criterio de
terminalidad
muy buenos dias angela y gracias por la
oportunidad de visibilizar el caso por
medio de este medio bueno que te cuento
la primera notificación fue una carta
sumamente vacía que simplemente
informaba la cancelación del
procedimiento
posteriormente y luego de casi que una
pelea con la ips en co2 se nos facilitó
el acta del comité que tomó esta segunda
decisión
de retractación
en la que tampoco se expone un motivo
claro el motivo parece ser que es una
aparente mejoría en que se vio en una
entrevista por parte de los médicos que
salió hace una semana pero no hay ningún
motivo médico fundado porque nada cambió
la situación de mamá no cambió la
situación médica mamá no cambió
hasta el momento como para que el comité
haya tomado esta decisión bueno y además
finalizar no porque para ustedes a todas
luces esta es una violaciones de los
derechos humanos de su mamá y por qué
insisten ustedes en que ella necesita
que se respete este derecho a morir
dignamente
bueno es una ordenación de los derechos
porque ella era un derecho que ya ella
había adquirido ya había tomado la
decisión del día y la hora en la que
consideraba que era ideal para tú
partida de este mundo de la forma más
digna posible
como te digo yo creo que la viralización
del caso generó algún tipo de presión
porque la única razón válida que se
encuentra es
lav
mejoría a criterio de los médicos del
comité de mi mamá que se evidencia en en
la entrevista una cosa que ya notar y es
que en la sentencia hace 233 de 2021
este criterio de terminalidad fue casi
que aún persiste puedes irte fue abolido
por la corte constitucional en esa
decisión decisión que está vigente bueno
y a partir de esta decisión creo que a
mi mamá se le debe reconocer el derecho
a no tal escucho a partir de esta
decisión que se tomó qué opciones se ven
ustedes para el futuro de su mamá van a
seguir insistiendo con el procedimiento
de la eutanasia
si tu decisión no ha cambiado para nada
ella quiere seguir dando la pelea yo
estoy dispuesto a ayudarla y apoyarla en
esto con el mayor amor del mundo
ella lo necesita porque así lo considera
básicamente porque cree que su vida ya
no es digna yo creo lo mismo y cree que
ese es la forma más loable de ponerle
fin de manera digna a su vida la única
acción que nos queda es la acción de
tutela que quizá una eventual segunda
revisión por parte de otro comité eso es
lo que se está evaluando y agotaremos
todas las opciones para
que se le reconozca la muerte digna mamá
porque su deseo perfil bueno y
finalmente porque usted cree que este
caso no solamente es importante para su
familia sino que debería ser un caso de
ejemplo para las personas que desean
acceder a la muerte digna
porque la eutanasia es un tema que
genera cierta renuencia
en una gran cantidad de personas e
instituciones y por lo tanto es un tema
del que no se ha hablado la suv del que
no se ha hablado lo suficiente entonces
este caso va a permitir que se hable del
tema que cada quien pueda dar su opinión
nunca me verán ni a mi mamá
criticando las opiniones de las demás
personas pero bien sea a favor o en
contra es pues un tema del que hay que
hablar y que ojalá afecte este caso y la
viralización sirva para lo que mi mamá
desea es un cambio en el imaginario de
la sociedad respecto al tema de la
muerte digna